Have you ever craved something late at night
and even though it seems like a hassle,
you just have to make it? I've been craving churros all day today,
so I just decided to make some before going to bed.
Started by making my caramel sauce
by letting my sugar turn an amber color,
whisking in some butter and heavy cream
before transferring it over to my glass jar to cool.
Then started on my churros,
which was just some water, sweetener,
some oil that I let come to a boil on the stove,
and once it was boiling
I pulled it off and added some flour before giving that a good mix.
Set that aside and made my sugar cinnamon mixture,
but I used monk fruit sweetener for this
and then transferred my churro dough to this little gadget.
Heated up my coconut oil for frying and then working in batches,
up my churro dough into it until it was golden brown.
While it was still hot, I gave it a good toss in the sugar mixture
and repeated that with all of my churro dough.
This little midnight snack hit the spot.
A little crunchy on the outside,
soft in the middle. Stunning.